[Music]
coca-cola semicolon after status hi
consumer data gokigen ability gnocchi
not hockey mandate Rosie O'Donnell
prepare a
myiasis curve a semester minakata dr.
oliver small screen evil Macarena
karma-yoga cocoon antenna feed our
psyche honest Madara
I'm Sonic a little blue ball of super
energy in an extremely handsome package
and in order to save my planet I had to
come to yours wherever what yours it is
the rock president 20 minutes ago an
energy surge knocked out power across
the entire Pacific Northwest who's there
why are you hiding out in my garage the
entire military is after me good morning
my rural chump I'm going to give you
five seconds to tell me where it is
[Music]
happening me oh my god stop the car
right now the world's largest rubber
band ball we gotta see it no this is not
some fun family road trip Yeah right it
was lame gift shop was cool though you
can lay low here for a while so what are
we gonna do now whoa let me show you how
it's done
[Music]
so should we get out of here yeah time
to go you won't get away from me you got
car insurance right
to die
no but thank you for asking
[Music]
how are you not dead I have no idea
[Applause]
[Music]
you throw your life away for this silly
little alien he's my friend
good times
that was an illegal left by the way
and I'm using it to protect my
I'm glad
the blue
so you're supposed to be Tom's best
friend that he won't shut up about well
I don't see the appeal
that is very gross
[Music]